sometimes watching a movie isn't enough
you also want to eat that movie that's
why there's movie recipes today we're
with chef George Pagonis at Cappadocia
in Washington DC we have challenged him
with making an offering worthy of the
load of clocks chef Petronas has
prepared a list of essential ingredients
to do just that
they are spit-roasted Pig we're gonna
eat the Beast pea shoots I mean look at
him fits like a little jungle and red
onions because boys don't cry except yes
they actually do a whole lot Joe George
so Lord of the Flies what were the Flies
uh probably still best known as a
classic novel by probably going there
I've been to movies made out of neither
one of them super memorable no no this
was the first book that I was told to
read in school that really captured me
yeah and we had we had just read The
Iliad this is seventh grade yeah
reading The Iliad in seventh grade is a
bad idea so I hated that and then she
selling this next book or the fly and
she spent a whole class period telling
us now there are two stories in this
book now what she was talking about
ultimate Lea was that Lord of the Flies
is sort of a microcosm of humanity yeah
what you have is you have one side which
is the democracy side and even how
democracy fails and everything like that
the other side you have well let's just
do anything we want and everything is
great and whatever it's the outback
fails as well
is maybe the most memorable or the flies
on film The Simpsons parody yes when
Bart says we're gonna live like kings
damn hell out king
it also gave us Ralph and the taste like
Bernie so let's hope that we don't get
any forest berries that taste like birds
yeah we don't want anything that tastes
like burning in this
very strong possibility we're going to
be getting pig yeah very very strong
because that's one of the that's the
animal that they're searching and
seeking out and they call a kid piggy
yeah yeah you know you have to hope that
some of the bloodier jet elements of the
story won't really make it into the dish
right right just don't want to see any
human heads on a spine of that because
that's not food yeah for you or anything
that's just symbolism like they just put
a plate that has nothing on it that
would that would be terrible
what if he makes a plate where he splits
it down the middle in one side is chaos
on one side is democracy and order that
would be awesome
it makes it yeah
you guys know hey do it wait oh wow it's
so good this looks amazing
hopefully it tastes as good as it looks
what are we looking at here so today I
prepared for you spit roasted pork it
cooked for about 10 hours over our wood
fire in our spit Roasters is that the
one I saw spinnin when I came yes right
into that and then on the bottom we have
a little bit of a beluga lentil puree
with a little bit about amman spice some
slow roasted tomatoes Beluga a pea shoot
tabbouleh and then a misfit roasted pig
with um a recent vinaigrette on top all
looks very much like a dish that
represents Lord of the Flies yes there's
there's greens in here and got the pig
of course any of the earth tones with
the lentil yeah like with some kind of
like country oh I can feel like I went
curry with spike this is really good it
is falling apart in my mouth full yeah
it's not 10-hour spit-roasting the delet
that old old cooking Oh cooking methods
this puree is awesome it's got you said
you've got curry of it yeah so of Oh
Devon is like a French curry mix spice
mixture and when I cook the lentils i
saute some onions and i totally the
curry really nicely without man some
white wine and I like the heat what
exactly know how many things are
contributing to it but it's just the
right amount for me I'm not a super big
heat guy but I like I like a little bit
of it was perfect but like I love
cooking with heat as well I just feel
like sometimes when you have a dish as
too much heated close your complete
entire mouth and I kind of I want to say
ruins a meal but you just don't have
that great of an experience for the dish
I like to make sure it's hot but then it
kind of mellows out of the yeah yeah
this is giving me heat but I'm still
able to taste everything falling so I
love it yeah well and then like that's
it kind of like a balance I try to
create like if you are if it is getting
too hot you have the tabbouleh
that's a nice refreshing salad then you
have the the the pureed it'll coat your
mouth and kind of help extinguish
whatever is quite a cucumber in this
there is you cumber in that some pickled
ramps some
radish oh man it's really good I'm
really think I did not expect all the
different ladies like sometimes when you
when you showcase all like the showcase
the dishes and you showcased like all
like the ingredients that go with it
everyone like how it looks at you might
just trust me
yeah it works yeah it does definitely
works man that's why you are you and
they are the eggs thanks to George for
the perfect pork make sure you head over
to the community table channel to hear
more from him and all the other chefs we
got dining out with thanks for watching
and we'll see you next time
move the recipes
[Music]